autre discipline autre championne de
France sa spécialité le tir sacré cet
été elle lave les Oise Agadir visent
désormais les JO de Paris 2024 ces
chances de médailles sont réelles dans
une discipline tout en maîtrise physique
et mentale Audrey Champigny la rencontre
en entraînement à Blois
à 21 ans Agadir a déjà tout d'une grande
un titre de championne de France une
médaille de bronze au mondiaux par
équipe junior
s'approchaîne cible les JO de Paris
l'objectif ça va être justement donc
d'aligner le petit rond qui est juste
ici avec celui-ci et justement la cible
au bout une fois qu'on aura tout aligné
parfaitement normalement c'est un 10
pour viser dans le mille ou plutôt dans
le 10 une carabine de 22 long rifle et
de petits diabolos de plomb d'un calibre
de 4,5 mm on va l'armée côté plat vers
l'avant comme ceci et après on va
pouvoir baisser et là la carabine est
chargée à 10m le 10 va faire un demi
millimètre de diamètre positionné de
profil le bras porteur calé sur le
bassin et l'écart des pieds mesurés au
centimètre près ne reste qu'un détail
quand je vais installer ma joue sur le
busc je vais pouvoir garder les deux
yeux ouverts et voir la cible tout
simplement en cachant mon oeil gauche
d'une certaine manière tout va être dans
l'installation du cachet au millimètre
près pour pas qu'on voit trop ce qu'il y
a autour d'un calme olympien Agathe dans
sa bulle concentré
c'est à l'âge de 7 ans kagate commence à
manier la carabine sportive au club de
Blois pour suivre les traces de son
grand frère très vite ces tirs font
mouche poule France de Wattignies près
de Lille pendant 5 ans elle intègre
ensuite l'INSEE en septembre 2021 tout
emmenant des études de biologie à la
Sorbonne
athlète de haut niveau Agathe s'entraîne
jusqu'à 20h par semaine j'ai une petite
préférence à 50 mètres donc je pense que
si je suis qualifiée aux idiot ce sera
plus à 50 mètres après en plus de ça il
y a du monde à 10 mètres donc ça risque
d'être difficile pour moi mais si je
suis qualifié pour les deux je serai je
serai la plus heureuse avant de viser
l'eau olympique Agathe doit d'abord
passer les sélections en décembre puis
obtenir le maximum de points en
compétition c'est normalement la ville
de Châteauroux qui accueillera les
épreuves de tir sportif pour les JO 2024